et je discutais avec une jeune fille
voilà on décide de poursuivre la
discussion chez moi elle vient et elle
me dit mais je viens je suis avec une
copine donc est-ce que je peux venir
avec elle et je dis bah évidemment plus
on est fou plus on rit et donc du coup
bah oui mais j'avais pas le choix de
départ on commence à discuter on boit un
verre et un moment une des deux celle-là
avec qui je discutais me dit tu veux pas
qu'on aille dans la chambre pour
discuter plus
longuement voilà et on se met dans la
chambre et un moment elle reçoit un SMS
et j'entends la porte de chez moi claqué
et donc du coup
les petits soupçons et il me dit et
c'est ma copine elle est partie elle a
plus de cigarette elle va industrielle
va acheter des cigarettes mais sa carte
passe pour distributeur faut que je
rejoigne on revient elle part et elle
revient pas et puis bah au bout d'un
moment donc du coup je vais dans le
salon je regarde il manquait un tableau
mon iPad et une montre moi j'ai un
copain à moi qui m'appelle en disant
Jean-Michel tu as pas reçu tu t'es fait
rien vu voler hier soir comment tu sais
ça il dit parce que la fille qui t'a
volé ta montre elle s'en est vantait
elle l'a vendue dans un quartier de
Paris voilà en 18e elles sont des
bandits et c'est la menthe de
Jean-Michel maire elle l'a vendu à un
prix qui était dix fois inférieur à
celui que je l'avais